per me va benissimo più bella ciao non
siamo tornati ma vi ringraziamo per
tutti i messaggi carivit che ci avete la
cosa avevamo appunto bisogno di prendere
una pausa e ora siamo più forte del
primo
preparatevi perché arriveranno
tantissimi video e pc quindi mi
raccomando attivate la campanella così
non ve li perdete e oggi facciamo una
nuova challenge al quale tre colori di
lime chan perché abbiamo già fatto un
sacco di challenge in cui se diamo tre
colori di glitter tre colori di colla
tricolori di quello che superano bendati
1 slime alla volta e poi dovremo
mischiarli tutti assieme e vediamo di
che colore diventa curiosa carlisle
abbiamo qua abbiamo degli slam già
pronti ovviamente sarà il corpo della
orbitz sono novissimi ma questo non
super curioso di vederli sono profumati
sono 12 i colori sono super morbide
vediamo comunque potete trovarli in
edicola sono solamente due 90 l'uno in
più vi daranno anche la rivista in
allenato tanti turisti di vedere come
sto facendo vincere
che cos'è critica un ritiro in blu
perché è fatto carico quindi tre colore
blu ce ne sono c'è un celeste blu scuro
europa così faccia il piacere
e bello è quello vero che mi capiti miti
assoluti 37 questi gialli li piazzano
tac ma che l'arancione conti mettono in
crisi di tornare a digione grecia è
un'offesa di sentire i profumi di tutti
abbiamo un ospite speciale oggi che
forse rimarrà sempre con noi
ho pagato che mi ha regalato mio
fratello e mia cognata di opere dato un
nome rimesse nei commenti che nome
volete che diamo al nuovo arrivato il
nostro pappagallo allora mettetevi
comodi nostra timberlake se volete
vedere altre challenge iniziamo subito a
quando era ora
amici è stato fatto carta forbice sono
carta favorite dallo scarto fa più basso
[Applauso]
io vi darei ancora più agitato del
solito non perché ha mangiato il
cioccolato ma perché dal fatto che non
facciamo video e non vede bene davvero
tutto senza sfogliatella che abbiamo
mangiato di nascosto
mamma mia non perdere silurate questo
tecnico devo mettere di nuovo linea ci
stanno più sono 1 mentre domani non mi
piace non solo di come sto
non voglio fare con il marito ei figli
questo è più bello ok non sono qua si
allora sono parto da qui così sono tre
film allora non versano verde non verde
dove ho visto questo non perde ok
vediamo se è fortunato
peccato comunque ad esempio ne prendo
questo colpo forse va bene ma proprio
bene dalla quale ecco mesi di proteste
viola
secondo messa di gelsomino certa di
lampone animazione stati con fiore dei
big band da tavolo che li chiudi sacco
di più aspetta aspetta sole è il
cioccolato cioccolato dai soli capi lo
precedono anche tre davanti
cos'è ero sul posto dire posso parlare
onorevole del rosso e rottami quello ci
viene insegnato
io voglio questo presto che era un dito
e mezzo bello peccato perché mio ad
aprire questi che sono troppo curiosa e
poi passiamo gli altri due di mischia
aspetta allora questo il magazine come
questo ma dicendo mi faccio vedere uno
sneak peek vediamo allora il mio si
chiama a tratti cake invece il tuo si
chiama round cerri strawberry di fragola
e il mio di torta stessi diventerà come
questo torta loro fuga lo sentiamo i
suoni adesso scoppiettanti
wow che bello sembra che ci sia la mente
dentro tipo però è più appunto tipo
bottone infatti si chiamano con tom
cruise e il prof
ovviamente ecco qua il mio primo live
trucchi e tante veniamo ora a quello di
vitale si deve sentire subito amore
io anch'io super favoloso ma si sa quasi
di g
molto grosse bellissimo
[Musica]
super favoloso sentire odore ancora come
band vedo di ieri di mischia di fisso
non so come scegliere ma devi scegliere
voluto procedere lei va bene stavo
parlando con vitale a quelle sommacal
allora a spazi maggio diventerà questo
sia fortunata erano al centro di verde
con la nostra partita
che bello commissione si compie la sua
felicità o presadiretta papa angeli cui
pescare così no
note leo messi così così poi mischiare
meglio io lo so tu vuoi fare caschi blu
membri già preso to me né per affianco
era un blu quando potete se riesco a
prendere quel blu è un altro colore
molto forte che colore c'era rosso sì se
anche prima magari il rosso blu il viola
con questo qui marroncino scuro magari
bordo dai matteo cappè dove sono sono
sottoscritti lunghi due sono in due file
scusa
allora mi sono riparate che io questo
devo già aperto perché non troppo
impaziente volevo vedere ma come papà e
poi dici a me che sono il paziente
togliamo e prima ancora di per il viso
aperto qualche giorno fa era tempo
questo è bellissima vediamo un po sembra
bene e procaccio e poi lo più piaccio
perché anche i grossi e anche questo e
rumori scoperti come se lo un disco tipo
così il mio un po
[Musica]
che bello che come ogni team è però più
bello ha detto sembra capita di unicorno
da ieri dunque detto di vedere
si chiama che ci riprenderemo inter
limone una gravità è un album aiuta
botte glossy dalla gravità frizzante la
granita al limone frizzante oppure le
caramelle interessante è che per i cari
ho fatto una specie di rosa e non un
gelato al cioccolato e al limone ma
perché io mi piace troppo schiaccia ma è
mio nome lo deve nominare ordinato ecco
io ho fatto la prima mossa finora tra le
più belle per meno di armi e bellissimo
celeste viola sono belli mi piace ai
colori della roba del lecce
[Musica]
è questa una decisione importante perché
l'ultima si sta chiamando questo mi sta
chiamando a manca fortunato ho prodotto
un altro posto rosa evidenziatore è
bellissimo molto fortunato brilla brilla
[Risate]
chiudi gli occhi socchiusi apri gli
occhi io vi aspetta no posso prendere
questo vai dove sono tutti questi ok che
colore
quanti piacevole per farlo si è invece
un gruppo sono invece prato inglese
tocca il mio rosa fluo che bello stato
proprio fortunate questa preghiera per
questo colore è stupendo big babol tipo
veramente messo proprio così anche verso
un che per loro bellissimo film ore 23
schiacci morisco
chiamate così perché si starà benissimo
per il viale celeste vediamo un po
[Musica]
facile per i colori che bene silenzio
ma che bello stupendo il proprio prime
unicorno questo ai colori bellissimi ma
perché un mistero tutto e vediamo di che
colore diventa che se è così con le
sfumature mi piace un sacco
se volete tenere le sfumature non
continuate a mischiarlo invece potete
continuare a rischiarlo alimenterà di un
colore più uniforme tu qua è diventato
una sorta di dio la rosa compresi shark
ora in ora proseguiamo dunque detto di
sentire il profumo di questo rende
anch'io so di mela verde il colore
non è bello con loro verso la si può
fare un green screen crescono il
marroncino al metanolo caraibi allora io
voglio fare cuore verde questo è lo
slime cuore verde però ci vuole un pò
tipo di un po di pazienza la fase che ti
in ben sentissimo mamma mia
adesso ci dobbiamo tagliare non taglia
montagna si è fatto vedere che ho fatto
maionchi carino prossimo per un altro
mese
diciamo di orta una torta una porta
questo è lontanissimo
hai visto sono troppo bravissimo adesso
proviamo mischiarlo per un po di più dai
vediamoci sociali di tutte le sfumature
bellissimi che non vedi che i colori
diventano marroncino chiaro per ora
malore è stato preso carlo del canone mi
è molto più bello secondo voi prima di
votare però abbiamo da offrire agli
altri
dobbiamo sempre più che io volevo dire
solo una cosa che vi profuma di più
stupendo questo fa i suoni smr
scoppiettanti ecco questo arancione wow
vediamone un altro ha detto che volevi
così lo volevo fatto all'inizio infatti
voce hano super pro fumarlo guarda la
schiuma barbara è questo che è una sorta
di viola scuro del duomo 1 m coupé anche
questi colori sono stupendi da questo
celiento di antonino asta un bambino di
montebuono
[Musica]
bellissimo bello perché sono insomma
super glossy poi software riescono le
super acceso inizia così mi ha detto che
cos'è la prima lavoro lo score parla
[Risate]
guarda molto bello grazie a questo
quello che mi piace di più avendo
preferito ma il libro brucia ancora
bellissimo questo allora prossimo apre
il giallo e il blu è un po di cura bella
l'italia diventerebbe la più il verde
vede mio va bene caffè verde non è
proprio un verde fluo evidenziatore lui
mi fido
hai visto che la pioggia ma di menta
figlio di un po
[Musica]
bellissima che questa capitale aprirà
l'ultimo questo giallo
vediamo stessa di limone ma bisognerà
ossia di limone si può però tipo
lemongrass si trova citronella qualcosa
del genere non so forse limone nipponico
ma cosa memoria e limone one plus
progresso alzi la mano
piace giallo e anche viaggio limone
limone cioccolato purissimo po strano
per la particolare come riporta quindi
ecco tutti gli altri treni che abbiamo
aperto il colore sono pazzeschi
veramente super luminosi bellissima
tomba
eppure mi piace che devo fare tantissimo
soprattutto orbi fateci sapere nei
commenti qual è il colore che vi piace a
me questo che una sorta di dio c'è in
realtà tutti quel che sarà la squadra
non bellissimi che potete trovarli ne
dica treno volta e ora vi lascio a
quattro mesi contro catilina
giustificare per vedere le nostre altri
sollers line modi divertenti cliccate su
quella che preferite e buona visione
ciao